three days after the attacks on the
Radisson Blu Hotel people here in the
capital bamako still feel unsettled at
this newsstand people have gathered to
discuss the latest events ah loo malian
it's not just Molly that's crying the
whole world is something like this
should never happen again well I'm very
sad it can't go on like this in Mali we
absolutely must find a solution oh you
poor dear madam da serra zoológico
Molly's government has called for three
days of national mourning all flags are
at half mast after two different
militant Islamist groups claimed
responsibility Molly's vice president
said that a third group has also claimed
responsibility the Messina Liberation
Front whose main area of activity is
central Mali they've been able to
install complete insecurity in all the
zones where they are present so like I
said they also carried out attacks on
scums and killed military people in the
past and they attack anything that is a
symbol of the state of the government at
the moment there's a lot of confusion
and Molly regarding the people behind
the terrorist attack for many years
Molly has been a haven for different
Islamist groups but with the attack on a
prestigious hotel in the center of the
capital terrorism has reached a new
level here